[Music]
welcome to the data science hangout if
you're joining for the first time it's
nice to meet you i'm rachel
the data science hangout is an open
space for the whole data science
community to connect and chat about data
science leadership questions you're
facing and what's really going on in the
world of data science
so the sessions are all recorded and
shared to youtube as well as the data
science hangout site so you can always
go back and re-watch them and find
helpful resources there
i try to take some of the
suggestions and links in the chat and
put them up with the recordings as well
but we also have a linkedin group for
the hangout too if you ever want to
continue a certain discussion
uh tyler or hannah can put that in the
chat right now
but um yesterday marcos had an idea of
starting a show and tell like our show
and share thread in there every week so
the side project you're working on or a
cool tutorial tutorial or article you
found
um so maybe we can start those
conversations going in that group too
but together at the hangouts we're all
dedicated to creating a welcoming
environment for everybody so we love
when everyone can participate and we can
hear from all of you so there's three
ways you can ask questions here you can
jump in by raising your hand on zoom
you could put questions in the zoom chat
and just put a little star next to it if
you want me to read it and i can or i
could call on you to introduce yourself
and share some context
and then we also have a slido link where
you can ask questions anonymously too
and i'm sure you just shared that in the
chat as well so thank you
just like to reiterate we love to hear
from everybody so no matter your level
of experience or the area or industry
that you work in as well
but with all that i'm so excited to be
joined by my co-host for today
jay c well director of analytics at
harry rosen
and jay i'd love to just kick it off by
having you introduce yourself and maybe
telling us a little bit about your role
the company
and maybe also something you like to do
in your free time outside of work too
sure um so like uh rachel said i'm i'm j
sewell
i lead the analytics and data science
practice for harry rosen um if you
haven't heard of us we're a kind of
luxury men's retailer
based out of canada
so you know the company's been in
business for
60
oh god i should know this 68 years
um and uh you know we've had really an
analytics practice for the last 12 or so
i was one of the first to kind of join
as a as a junior analyst way back when
about 10
and a half years ago
uh at that point we were really just you
know kind of
slinging sql queries for the marketing
department and things like that it was
it was kind of
you know what you'd expected a retail
company in 2012 or whatever um
and one of the things i noticed right
off the bat was you know we had this
amazing data set
um
and uh and we were really really using
it we were kind of sharing it to some of
the sales people in the stores and
things like that we weren't really like
getting many insights from it it wasn't
being leveraged like it could be so i
kind of took it upon myself to show the
business a little bit of what what data
science could do um and so through that
i've kind of raised through the ranks
and and now i kind of lead the team and
um
yeah i mean
it's we're we're in our shop uh which is
one of the reasons i'm i'm kind of doing
this i love the language i love the the
platform and the community um and uh
yeah so we kind of have our hands in
in everything within the business and we
use r to power almost all of it um so um
yeah and what was the other thing oh
something i do in my spare time uh i
love to cook i'm a bit of a gourmand so
when i'm not you know
writing code or whatever i'm typically
cooking something i've actually moved
out to the country
we're surrounded by farms there's such
good food around so it's been amazing um
yeah that's what i'll do so
that's great thanks jay
i know when we were chatting a little
bit earlier you talked a bit about how
you're thinking a lot about building a
data data-driven culture and what that
really means
um
i'd love to hear how you're doing that
uh i mean
how am i doing it well so that's
you know like i mentioned you know harry
rosen's a pretty
long-standing company we have almost 70
years
uh in in the market um you know for a
lot a lot of that time like i said we
weren't really using data uh the way we
probably could right um so part of
growing a data science team is also
growing a company that wants to use that
data science team to its fullest uh and
to me that's kind of you know a really
good starting point for a definition of
a data-driven company
but the you know so the
the challenge we're sort of facing is
like how do we
how do we teach people the skills they
need to consume data and at the same
time how do we produce products you know
however that kind of manifests itself to
so that they can learn and grow with
that and like that's been our approach
i'd love to hear uh opinions from from
participants in the chat uh about like
how they would you know conceptualize
what a data-driven company is um
at the at the front of it and within the
last few years we've kind of
you know
placed data-driven culture as part of
our one of our core values right we call
it measure twice cut once really kind of
encapsulates uh part of that thinking um
but you can't just
say you know
we're gonna do this you actually have to
do it and you actually have to sort of
build not only you know the the the
knowledge understanding the data
literacy and the drive to
uh use data but then also you know the
products the the data sets the back end
everything that supports it um so yeah i
mean
how we've been doing it is kind of
inching forward slowly but surely uh so
we do you know some
some lunch and learns and things like
that with with people in the company we
try to you know build products really
iteratively we took agile very seriously
in the last couple years to to work
really closely with people we're
building products for to try to you know
deeply understand
how
they're approaching problems and how we
could help them use data to approach
those problems better uh and we found
that's been that's been a positive kind
of change in the way in the way we've
approached things um but yeah it's it's
an ongoing challenge i think and and one
that you know i don't think there's a
specific formula to solve but uh very
happy to kind of hear suggestions and
thoughts from from participants in here
about what they think because yes
absolutely
i see um manju you had unmuted for a
minute i wasn't sure if you were going
to jump in and add some thoughts there
too i'm sure i always seem to have
thoughts
but uh
yes
i have experienced this quite a bit i
feel in my mind if everybody has access
to the information
um
[Music]
there are a lot a lot of ideas get
generated how to enable it for the whole
organization uh
many times we run into roadblocks of
having access to particular
sorts of information
but i feel if all the departments could
have equal access
i think that would create like
data driven insights for the whole
company
yeah i mean that's that's a great point
and actually so one of the approaches
we've sort of taken to that and
you know this is
you know a long time ago somebody
convinced us to buy
buy into tableau we've never really
built much dashboarding on it but what
we have done is
uh is created data sets you know kind of
and made them available to some people
in various parts of the organization but
basically whoever wants it uh and we'll
sort of curate a data set and kind of
make it available so that somebody from
that team who has questions and is close
to the problems they're working on also
has sort of
wide and unfettered access to some data
about it to try to you know kind of
uh short while the
the game of telephone between the
question and answer so to speak um so i
mean that's that's been an approach i
think it's actually been pretty
successful but it's hard to scale
and it's hard to find pockets of the
business that that
and convince them to want and need that
because there's some training and
whatever involved too so
um but yeah that's a really good point
i'm curious to hear from you all maybe
in the chat too but what data driven
means for you at your companies too
and jay how did how did you first start
those conversations with
the business users i know you said you
had like the luncheon learns but is that
across the whole company
uh
i mean probably the first real
attempt at starting to build this um we
have a kind of senior leadership group
uh within the organization and kind of
the part of that was or the point of
that sorry was uh was to you know be
able to share knowledge and and you know
kind of leadership
wisdom and things like that across the
the company so one once or twice a year
we we pull in leaders from all over the
country uh we do a presentation i got a
chance to kind of get up and and you
know
like i think i titled my talk the seven
habits of highly effective data analysts
or some some something contrived like
that um and i tried to kind of kind of
convince everybody that like no matter
what their role in some way shape or
form they're touching data
they're learning from it and they're
using it and so they should learn some
habits of what good data analysts do
so that actually got a little bit of
traction going in terms of people being
a little bit more open to talk to our
team i think we were sort of seen as uh
as you know the the pretentious or
pedantic esoteric team that did all
sorts of weird algorithms and whatever
um so that that kind of opened opened
the doors but
really it's been a lot of frontline me
approaching a team trying to understand
what they do what their business
problems and issues are what challenges
they're facing
and get them open to the idea that
these aren't insurmountable and
sometimes there's data sitting right
there to help them at least you know
come up with answers quicker easier
faster better whatever it is
um so yeah those conversations are very
much it's more of a pull from my end
than it is a push right now and and uh
although you know it's starting that
tide is starting to turn a little bit
which is great
um
but yeah i've i've been out there
uh kind of mining for for business for
our team if that makes sense
that's great
can you give us an example of something
that the team
works on
sure um
so like i said we kind of service any
area that that needs it um
for a long time it was mostly the
marketing team just because you know
from from an audience generation
targeting point of view there's a lot of
applications there we have a lot of good
data about our customers and what they
buy and that sort of thing
um but lately uh the focus has been more
probably on store operations um
so we we've built recently an
app a mobile app we call it real time
pulse um
it basically just came out of a
conversation where one of the operations
leaders were like i just need real-time
data i need to get the pulse of the
business and we're just like all right
you keep using those words that's what
we're calling the app
um and it's really just uh you know a
way of taking some of the reporting that
was really slow or inconsistent or or
you know weekly or something like that
and put it right directly in the hands
of of the store
leadership
so they can pull up and see up to the
second what are the sales in the store
how are the various sales people
performing um how are they how are they
tracking to their weekly goals and
things like that and this has just been
an opportunity for us to kind of insert
some
and this is all built and shiny um and
this has been an opportunity for us to
sort of insert some insights and
intelligence into those layers so
instead of showing them you know a big
list of
numbers we're kind of trying to find
what are the insightful what are the
important figures that you need to look
at and pay attention to so that you can
make quick decisions uh throughout the
day
so that's been that's been probably one
of our most impactful
apps that we've built and and um
and that's been
probably our most widely used in terms
of like you know total hours of usage or
whatever uh so that's uh that's gone
stirred a lot of excitement in the
company just in terms of what we could
do for them that's that's not so much uh
more
traditional reporting looking so
yeah
i was just thinking what libby just said
in the chat as well it sounds like your
data people sometimes have to be sales
people a hundred percent yeah and we re
yeah getting in their shoes and
understanding
what they think about from day to day
and it's often not what you'd expect you
know coming from you know coming from a
math background and computer science and
things like that the way you approach a
problem is definitely different than the
way uh somebody who's day-to-day is
clientelling dealing with people um so
just trying to cross that barrier is is
sometimes a big challenge but part of
the fun of it i think yeah i see andrew
you just asked a question in the chat do
you want to jump in
or i can read it um
andrew said
i um don't know how to work with you
no worries welcome
uh i was curious how you organize and
prioritize the work especially when
there's multiple
teams departments that you're working
with and stakeholders so there's not a
single list that you're knocking out on
but but you still have a single team
that we're working with
yeah uh i mean prioritizing work is you
know it's like
uh what's that joke about the two
biggest problems in computer science or
cash invalidation and naming things well
the third one is like prioritizing your
work right um so you know everyone
everyone thinks their thing is the most
important thing
um we we have tried
uh probably a dozen different ways to
try to get agreement across the business
on what what our team should be building
at any time
and what we finally
kind of nailed uh nailed it down to is
um
you know we give
we we
we give um like a a
kind of value rating t-shirt size value
rating to something and an effort size
value rating to something put it in a
matrix
and then we open it up to our executive
and say tell us which ones you you want
us to do and they they go i like this
idea i like that idea if we have
different opinions we are we you know
kind of present an argument uh and then
we come up with
with our
our priority for the quarter uh and then
we go on right um how we get to that
value uh statement is typically a lot of
conversation with the team and trying to
figure out
um what their challenge and what their
business problem is actually you know
kind of uh how connected it is to
something like sales or efficiency or
things like that and that's that's
another part that i think like we're
we're trying to get better at i think
we'll always try to get better at uh but
yeah i mean it's it's definitely you
know like i said one of our biggest
challenges is picking the right
priorities and and
uh and making sure we can stick to them
like when you know if someone else comes
in and says no no no this this thing is
more important we have to stick to our
guns and know that like we picked the
right thing all along and uh
uh and
you know like have a good argument have
a good uh good logic behind that so that
so that we don't get sidetracked or
bottled and things like that but
yeah great question
it's really helpful thank you
i see eric you asked a question as well
do you want to jump in
yeah well i'm happy to be back finally i
don't have a meeting at this time it's a
miracle
so my my question is kind of loaded but
um i know for experiences i've had in
the past
sometimes it's easy to find a quick
solution to a reason a problem at hand
but
maybe taking that extra time to pursue
something that's a lot more innovative
that might have not been done before
can have big payoffs in the long run but
it might look a little risky sometimes
curious for your group how do you do
that do your does your group feel
empowered to take those kind of
calculated risks to do something
innovative
um and how how does that leadership feel
about that kind of that tug and pull
between getting something done quick
versus maybe taking a little time up
front to make something better maybe for
the future as you solve a problem
that's a that's a great question i mean
i i feel
um and and maybe this is me kind of like
with 10 years of elbowing out this kind
of space around me to to
i feel empowered by our leadership that
they trust
my judgment on that um and
typically
we will
we will look at a project with two
two kind of pieces of value when we look
at it's like this is the value to the
business problem and this is the value
to future work right so for example if
we're going to you know approach a
problem like
you know let's just put a linear model
into plumber and and fire it off and
whatever and that's you know going to
get us 80 of the way there or we can
develop a better data set we can develop
etc etc and we can turn that into a
package that we might be able to use
down the road
you know that that future work uh value
is taken into account right so i'll say
you know we'll spend three weeks instead
of one week or two months instead of one
month on this
in order to be able to use this
extensively in other
projects uh i i have gotten a lot of you
know
um
gotten a lot of leeway to to allow our
team to do that because i think our our
executive sort of seeds have seen the
payoffs from that before um but that you
know that's always a challenge but
sometimes
you just have to
you just have to
you know bring in the estimate with that
in mind rather than telling them that
you could probably do some
half-assed solution in a lot less time
because you know what it will bring to
your team later right
so yeah i mean
i guess you know that that's that's kind
of the answer is is
yes i feel empowered but also i i don't
always i don't always tell them the
other
you know the i don't always give them
the option for the for the quick
solution if we know we're going to get a
lot of value out of the better one
i've definitely done similar things
sometimes they don't need to know
everything right yeah exactly and i hope
they don't find this on youtube or else
i'm in trouble but
you know i've sucked worse things on my
podcast so you're fine okay
good to know
i see um
jan and apologies for miss pronouncing
your name but that you asked a few
questions in the chat i'd love to have
you ask those
oh thank you um i'm sorry i unable to do
my video no worries thank you so much
thank you
uh jay um the the way that i describe
you to collect your uh evaluation for
your data value um i thought is a great
uh process processes
really uh could stand as your base of um
make more value of your your data
selections
um but um so so according most of the
time your data do you think that your
data is belong to the business or belong
to the public or belong to the
data scientist or belonging process
yeah i mean
that's a tough question to answer i
guess because there's
i mean we have a lot of data right and
um
there's no i don't think there's a
really
fine line between what i think belongs
to
you know for example like i mean
definitely i wouldn't consider any of
our data public in the sense that you
know most of it is
customer data uh or related to customer
data in some way shape or form or it's
product data and it's related to you
know
a sweater or a pair of pants or whatever
it is um
and and
so you know but is you know is that data
owned by the customer in our in our kind
of minds and the way we approach it it
absolutely is
um in the sense that if a customer wants
it they can have it no one's ever asked
if they want us to get rid of it we have
mechanisms to do so and so on um but in
terms of the sort of second part of your
question is it owned by us or is it
owned by the company um
there's there's definitely some things
that we consider owned by us uh and
that's basically you know
um so the way we sort of structure our
you know build our data is like we
consider like a medallion type of
architecture where uh you know we have
the raw data that comes from our data
sources whatever we can siphon off of
you know our pos system or our crm
system cdp things like that
and then
we try to turn that into data models
that are useful to us in general and
that's you know part of those uh um
those kind of value-add
uh extra projects and when we're or
extra pieces of a project we're doing uh
is to go and say okay well you know
we're gonna use this type of data often
so we might as well make a
more standardized version of it we
consider that to be owned by us uh all
of the downstream
things that are that are that are uh
using it are dependent on that and if if
there's something wrong with it it's our
responsibility to fix and maintain it um
and uh and
yeah so so that's that's kind of where
we draw the line if we built it we own
it uh but it's typically built off of
data that i would say the company owns
or the customer owns in a sense right
but but if you um
transfer to somewhere else
now
how do you
how do you think this data will belong
to belong to the device or processing or
belong to the
like you climb a pattern belong to the
pattern that follows or you just discard
it which is a totally waste
yeah
so i mean can you give me an example of
like what you think like
transferring the data somewhere like you
know
so you are you are working for uh mit
right okay um you are for example if you
a graduate student you're going to
graduate right and then you're going to
find a job where you're doing that you
already own certain part of processing
and the data now
harvard business school says hey
like a cream
crime says uh we we are open 3d and
we're going to um select you or hire you
as our chief executive
data processing
analysis now
your technique going to be
a part of the
the technical uh belongings right now uh
sort of like a marriage
is
before marriage or after marriage and
then how do you do it
okay so usually i mean
am i getting it right then you're
talking more about the intellectual
property like how i would build that not
the actual necessarily the bits and
bytes itself but like yeah actually i
want to ask you is that um how do you
so
data itself has a value
and where are you processing it you
select the um
the population uh in certain purposes of
course that
that's all different categories but the
value that you created
um
it was
going to be belong to the private sector
or the popular like like a public
uh community community uh
society owned or how do you you know how
do you think that you're able to control
it and then in the certain regulations
that are according to
right um
you know i'll be honest i've never
really thought of it like that um that's
a good question i mean
so
so i guess i mean
the only thing that kind of comes to
mind is is um
the idea of kind of taking some of the
stuff that we that we've done and if
there's an application outside of
something that's sort of specific to
our business um that we could outsource
a you know earth open source sorry a
a package or or
something like that to kind of like give
back
that value back to the community i mean
i think that that's that's something
that we've considered we've never really
found a really good candidate in our
kind of package library we've built for
that
like a trade-off or something
i mean
well i mean like
you know there's there's no legal sense
in which i'm allowed to share our data
but i can definitely share you know what
we've done with it and try to give back
that way in a sense i'm i'm yeah i'm not
sure
uh there's anything that we could do
other than other than that type of
activity okay
thank you
i just want to make sure
i i'm sorry i just want to make sure to
get to some of the anonymous questions
too but
there was there was one that was um
going back to the shiny app that you had
created and asked if
the marketing of it as a real-time pulse
shiny app or like naming it had some
role in the success of the application
and if you think about like the
marketing of a shiny app
yeah i mean we we did we tried to build
we we drew a logo um you know we we
tried to make it um
seem
in in a sense as different as possible
from the usual experience
um
that that you know the stores had with
reporting so we're sort of coming from
and and it's still pretty widespread in
the company a lot of like old school bi
uh you know like oracle bi publisher
type of reports where you know you go in
you click some drop downs you hit run
and you know two minutes later a
spreadsheet comes up um that type of
thing you know is what the stores have
been used to for a very long time it's
what everybody has cut their teeth on
it's the way they think about consuming
data and we wanted to show them as
something as absolutely different as
possible and so we definitely did choose
ui
uh themes we
we created a logo we have a little
loading screen
we used a lot of kind of visualizations
and and color schemes that that line up
with marketing materials and sort of
internal
uh documents and things like that that
have been circulated we try to make it
as much of a
a packaged experience for for users as
we possibly could um and that that was a
very conscious decision on our part to
make sure
that this felt different and felt new um
so that you know we could get users
excited about
the idea that not only the idea of this
app but the idea that that there could
be others like this if they have you
know interesting problems to bring to us
this is the type of thing they could get
that's really interesting
is it with like all the company branding
too
um
definitely we have company branding on
it but again we're trying to make it um
uh we're we're trying to make it uh
uh
you know kind of
yeah we're trying to make it as as if
it's like an app they downloaded from
the app store although they didn't um
that's that was the kind of look and
feel we even we even showed users how to
kind of uh you know uh post posted as a
shortcut on their phones or whatever so
it opens full screen it feels like a pwa
we've structured it like a pwa um so so
yeah like that was it was very very
purposeful there is a little bit of
harry rosen branding but it's more you
know the branding of the app the
branding of our our team nice um just
curious what does pwa mean oh sorry
progressive web app it's okay it's yeah
it's yeah so it just feels like there's
no browser uh no browser
url kind of tab right now i see cool
um sam i see you asked a question on
setting expectations with leadership do
you want to jump in
yeah can you hear me yep can you go
perfect um a question on how do you set
expectations with the shiny apps for
example you create with leadership or
users to avoid feature creep sometimes
users they want you know but there's
additional features that can
throw the project off course and really
add resources that you might have
capacity for oh yeah we we have a we
have a word for this it's called the the
kitchen sink app right where the second
you start talking to people about it
they start imagining it's this catch-all
uh application that can solve all of
their all of the world's problems and
they start asking and asking so i mean
to me
uh the the biggest thing is like you
know be absolutely clear what the
objective is and that's you know so we
do a lot of work to try to try to and
again i don't think we're perfect at
this but you know when we're having
those initial conversations with you
know the line of business that's
supposed to use it we're trying to keep
the group relatively small and we're
trying to focus on describing the
problem and kind of putting that in like
a
like a problem statement and like a
vision statement for what the app is
supposed to be so that we can go to and
every time we meet with them we're sort
of referring back to that as many times
as we possibly can to kind of hammer it
home that this is what we're trying to
do right
um
and
yeah i see uh yeah other people have
seen the kitchen sink app come to life
um so
yeah we're
it's it's really it's really like a
people management problem and uh you
know it's it's really uh tempting as you
know a developer of an app to want to
solve people's problems so
you have to manage yourself and your
team as much as you have to manage the
people asking for this stuff
because you know your developers get
excited to solve problems they get
excited when people are excited about
their work
is really easy to feature creep um and
so
you know we're we try that kind of agile
approach of like let's hear let's let's
all agree on a vision statement and
let's iterate towards it and every time
we release something we ask is this
doing that um
and and
if if something could be done better it
means okay well let's revise our our
problem statement a little bit to see if
that fits in it and let's let's add to
our vision statement a little bit to see
if it fits and the second we kind of
hint that like this isn't fitting like
if there's too many ands in your vision
statement probably even more than one uh
you're starting to think should this be
another app
right um
you know keeping things separate is is
is pretty critical teaching people to
want and
and understand that is hard
thanks jay
i'm not sure how to ask this as a
question but i remember when we were
talking maybe a few months ago you
talked about um like when you decide to
reproduce reports or keep reports and
you call it internally like jay's razor
and i was curious if you could just talk
a little about a bit about that because
i think it'd be really helpful
yeah yeah sure so um we kind of have
this plan
over the next few years to migrate all
of our reporting uh into you know the
the the kind of platform we're building
we call it missouri it's the italian
word for to measure we do a lot of made
to measure clothing in the company so it
kind of resonates with people um and you
know has a kind of cool double meaning
so um
you know
we did an audit this is probably a few
years ago yeah pre-pandemic we did an
audit i think we had
a thousand reports it was like 900 and
something reports sitting out there and
the tool where you the tool that the
development team has been using forever
doesn't track who uses them so we're
sitting there going like we're not we're
not migrating 900 reports there's just
no way um so yeah we kind of developed
this this technique where rather than
you know
migrating a report i sit there and go
okay you guys use this report show me
show me
how you make a decision that impacts the
business from the data in this report
right um you know so a good question i
ask is like okay so imagine you pulled
this up and i went oh oh crap i just
found out this data is wrong and i gave
you brand new numbers and you like
you've never seen the before how does
your week change how does your month
change are you doing something different
now that i've shown you new numbers
and if you can't reasonably convince me
that your week or your month has changed
because the report was wrong
it's a useless report and we should not
be looking at it right so um
you know trying to get at you know
plugging information into actions and
into decisions and really kind of like
stripping down reports that aren't doing
that like if you're just looking at a
report in order to pass on that
information to somebody who's passing it
on this is kind of this game a telephone
or whatever it is um
it's time to go right um so we we
i use the analogy a lot of like um
you know we're not historians right
looking at a report about what happened
last week
you can't change it the sales were what
they were we sold what we did the
customers came in you can't do anything
right so unless you're using that to
figure out what
you're doing next week right like i so
the analogy i was using is like the
weather
weather report is a report everybody
uses right
everyone knows how to use it most people
use it every day right
what does the weather report do it tells
you how to make decisions do i need an
umbrella do i need a sweater should i
drive or walk to work
uh it's forward looking it's a forecast
who looks up the weather from last
tuesday
nobody who cares it already happened
right uh and so i'm trying to get people
to think about reporting more like the
weather report it should be if it's not
directly telling you what's going to
happen you should be thinking about what
do i know about what's going to happen
because of this report and
how can i make a decision to accommodate
that or to take advantage of it
so yeah that's kind of the razor when
when people can't answer that question
with enough authority
i'm like yeah we're killing this one and
it's and it's gone um
and yeah so that's that's kind of our
approach it's been pretty successful
i love that
i was thinking that about some of the
like i don't know even salesforce
reports or things that we look at
um i see libby you had a
you said you had a similar way to
prioritize reports do you want to jump
in on that
um sure yeah oh my god embarrassing
um
yeah so our org
i i was just part of kind of a
modernization effort where we were going
through and prioritizing things and um
there was some prioritization that
already existed at least the logic
behind it did
and as we were going through all these
reports just like pouring through a
billion reports that there's only one
that was high priority that was like you
know top top level priority only a few
that were kind of mid-level and
everything else was either like you said
outdated or um didn't meet the criteria
and the criteria was kind of like
who looks at it and then what decision
are they making with it and if it's not
elt that's looking at it it's not
executive leadership team that's looking
at it then it's like an automatic bump
down kind of and then
if you're not making an actual
either strategic or operational decision
with it on a daily basis and it's not
updated uh you know on a regular you
know time scale
then yeah why are you looking at it and
you kind of like
already
spent so much time just looking at all
of these reports
that
it kind of blows my mind that like oh we
can spend like four months digging
through these 50 to 100 reports just to
find one that
somebody actually looks at every day the
data's up to date
um and moving forward with less feels
like corporate minimalism to me and i
really like it
yeah it's it's freeing
it's free yeah yeah
yeah that's great
andrew i see you had a follow-up
question to this report conversation as
well if you want to jump in
yeah i imagine that uh
there are many vendors who would like to
sell you a reporting system to put all
of the things in i'm curious to hear
more about how you you know what
uh what you were looking for and how
you're getting it you mentioned the
custom thing so i imagine it's not just
a straight off the shelf thing
well yeah so it's built on rstudio
connect actually um
so that's you know that's the vendor and
one of the reasons i'm i'm here today is
you know just conversations through uh
speaking with our studio um but uh but
yeah i mean
we we've been approached by i mean you
name it tableau looker power bi like
everyone wants to sell us their solution
um
my my typical kind of uh question i ask
is is uh
you know like how well can i version
control this how well can i like how
flexible is it in terms of you know
creating writing to a custom
a custom data model like how can i
incorporate machine learning i've never
got a good answer on
all or even most of those types of
questions from from most vendors that
come kind of come to us and try to sell
us their solution
and so
you know we i stick to my guns like i
love a code first approach to problem
solving uh i think it it has so many
benefits that outweigh the
you know to me slightly extra time it
usually takes to get a project off the
ground um
and so far we've had like nothing but
success kind of building our own
building and managing our own code that
uh i i it's almost like
you know i kind of know how these
conversations are gonna end before they
begin um
i don't know if that kind of answers
your your question but like
like
our
our platform is really just
uh a way of hosting and
and orchestrating shiny apps uh and and
plumber apis and things of that nature
um
you know we're we're sort of
always on the lookout for good ways to
do that in the back end and our studio
connect has been a great way to do that
in the back end um
but in the front end like what what
those things do like the the the kind of
logic layer and presentation layer in
that scheme has always been code first
definitely um
you know if one day we moved to python
or whatever maybe i don't know but it
will probably still always remain uh you
know
code we build and code we maintain and
code we uh we kind of pour our heart and
soul into
i don't know does that answer your
question
oh you might be needed andrew
thanks yeah does answer okay great
thank you i see a few other questions
popping into the chat right now aj i see
you just asked one do you want to jump
in
yeah just uh how do you manage user
adoption right so there's so many new
things rolling out as you said looking
forward reports like a weather style
approach how do you make sure people are
up to date on the latest and the
greatest are there
any sessions or
so yeah i mean we're a small team it's
kind of hard to manage the time it takes
to sort of do training sessions but
we're really we're really trying and i
think like the more time we put into it
the more value we get out of it so it's
something i'm trying to steer uh steer
us to do more of um great documentation
like you know a lot of the applications
we build um have documentation kind of
like built into them as like a little
user guide tab or something like that
with with what's hoping to be a lot of
information
but we also i mean this is something
relatively new like we monitor the logs
of who's using what app and we can sort
of see like an rco connect has a
connector to postgres that we leverage a
lot of kind of reporting on in postgres
internally to see like who is using our
apps how how long are they spending on
them that sort of thing um we're also
trying to develop when we're working on
a package right now
um that's that's gonna help us kind of
do a little bit more fine-grained
reporting so we can see like what
features of apps are being used by users
and that's hopefully going to help us
ask better questions when we go back to
them for
for uh for feedback so
you know the feedback mechanism built
into the sort of agile process is really
helpful but it's better when we can say
hey look we built this thing you guys
asked for and this tab never gets
touched like is it because you realize
you didn't
uh you didn't see
uh you didn't like you you thought it
would be more useful or it's not
providing the information you thought it
would or or what is it so that we have a
bit more focused questions because right
now we have to kind of pull that out of
users uh and that's not as uh that's not
as efficient but
yeah i mean user adoption is is is
critical
um and the hard part is capturing
people's attention and then the other
hard part is figuring out what to do
when you don't have it um and so
yeah um i guess another one i'll lean on
is like getting
leadership uh on board with this so um
you know like our our president and uh
and ceo is a big proponent of our team
uh he does a lot of work to
convince others that they should care
about the reporting that we're giving
him and them uh and so like that's
that's another one that's been
a really big help in terms of a growing
adoption of our products
great thank you
thank you
kind of on that note in terms of like
sharing best practices i see eric you
asked a question as well do you want to
jump in
yeah yeah it's definitely related but um
as your team finds great solutions
develops great apps or cool analytical
pipelines what are efforts that your
group takes to make sure that you're
sharing that knowledge across and that
you know people are learning from each
other i don't know if you have like
internal user group sessions or shared
learnings or things like that
yeah
that's a very apropos question i swear
like you do you why are you spying
honestly we uh we so we recently
so we kind of in in 2019 had this idea
of the like starting a center of
excellence for analytics and the
pandemic kind of put a tie boss to that
for a little while
but we recently kind of took that off
the shelf and we're trying to build that
up and
part of it is like you know there's
other people in the in the organization
who are either power users of our
our output um or they're doing kind of
analytics
in their area or they're um you know
just basically just data-driven people
we want to uh create a kind of space for
them to share knowledge and things we've
actually chosen
and this might sound terrible and i bet
a bunch of people are going to get
goosebumps when i say this we chose jira
service desk as the kind of
platform to do this so we have a place
for people to come in and write requests
or ideas or whatever and and also just
see uh work going through so if we had a
release for an app we have you know a
ticket for that release that people can
kind of watch the progress of but really
for internally if somebody's doing
something they can put it in
in the service desk and and talk to any
member of the of the uh analytics center
of excellence and get some advice what
data would i use for this like have you
guys seen this result does this make
sense to you and so on and so forth um
you know
that's we we're sort of just in the
infancy of that kind of experiment but
uh like that's kind of our our solution
to that in in a sense um is to see if we
can create a a little kind of shared
space for for people that are either you
know analysts by title or analysts by
by trade um
to kind of just you know talk about this
stuff um
i don't know how far reaching it'll get
uh it's kind of again still brand new
but that's that's kind of our our idea
and having that you know uh
that
knowledge base start to grow and build
in in a single place with some search
ability and
you know with confluence kind of keeping
documents and whatever together
i'm hoping
we kind of create that but that's that's
uh
yeah that's so far our idea to solve
that problem
yeah that's very helpful having that
central place people can go to is so
much better than just typical send that
person there's a message or send them an
email that gets lost in the abyss of who
knows exactly yeah and no one can search
for it somebody new comes on board how
do you find you know so
uh yeah i know jira jira a lot of people
pull their hair out over jira um and
i've done the same thing uh many times
but it's kind of like
what's that old winston churchill quote
um it's like uh jira is the worst
solution for this except for all the
other ones
so so far you know we've had a lot of
success with it internally and so you
know we're hoping to kind of keep that
but it does have its frustrations but
yeah i mean i think the benefits like
like you're sort of hinting at like what
hopefully away the
the frustrations
cool
i'm curious i'm curious for people
listening into if you have your own
community like user groups what you use
or how you share information internally
too
if you want to put it in the chat or
just share share tips with each other
um libby i think you had a you had a
follow-up on
the features that are being used and
certain apps you want to jump in and add
context to that one
yeah um it was just a selfish selfish
question so you were talking about being
able to look at what features are being
used what tabs they're clicking on
um
i stopped using connect with my
organization
right before the like connect api came
out so i'm aware of it and i was like oh
this is so cool but i didn't get to use
it from an org side um so i was
wondering if you were like
building server-side events that you
were harvesting or if this is in the
connect api somewhere i'm not aware of
i'm just kidding yeah so it's actually
separate to the connect api but we are
putting it in the same physical database
so the postgres database that connect is
feeding to we've created basically like
an extension uh database for that um and
the reason for that is we're hoping
hoping to take advantage of some
connections like if we know a user's
guid
then we can use that to say this user
did these actions or whatever and we can
connect those things together um
again this is
we're still sort of an experimental
phase so we're not sure we can do as
much of those things as we want um but
that was kind of the idea but really at
its core this is going to be a front-end
package so a package that we can kind of
load into a shiny app and basically call
almost like a logging function uh you
know inside observe events or things
like that to say this is happening this
is how the user clicked here the user
did this uh and that's gonna that's
basically gonna connect to a plumber api
that's gonna do the hard work of writing
this to the right log or whatever so
essentially we're going to be creating
just a a giant
almost like google analytics ripoff um
for for our thing and i know some people
have even uh and we consider this some
people connected google analytics to
their shiny apps um we tried it out we
could never get it to work
yeah so look it up if you can if you can
if you can figure out how to get to work
please let me know we could never quite
follow along um but uh but yeah so
that's that's the idea we'll have this
plumber api just listening um for any
old event uh from from any one of these
things and the the trick is we're trying
to make it as low overhead as possible
so it doesn't slow anything down at all
right you're not like harvesting
billions and billions yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly but uh yeah so it's going
to be on the developer to choose where
to put that in the code and to make sure
that we care like what we care about is
being recorded
so yeah
very cool yeah
shiny app developers have to be
half data scientist half like ux
designer and i'm never prepared to be a
ux designer so this part the like
harvesting information about the way
people are using it is more intuitive
for me than like designing it to be
better usable from the outset
yeah maybe we should all learn about ux
design well thanks jay yeah you're
welcome
thank you and i shared a link in the
chat that was like usage tracking
meetup recording with the connect api
but i'm
imagining that eric you probably have
some great resources for that too or
people from your podcast
as well if you want to share any others
in the chat
yeah yeah i definitely have lots of
thoughts about that i'll put some links
in the chat cool thank you
um tiffany i i see you asked a question
earlier too do you want to jump in
um
hi yeah i you just mentioned that you
had a smaller team
and i guess how do you manage
everyone's timelines and trying to um
work on one project or multiple projects
and deliver that to the people that you
need to get it to
yeah i mean so our team actually uh all
shameless plug we're hiring right now if
you're based in canada uh like we're
programming in r and shiny uh go to
harry rosen.com look at the careers page
you'll find data product developer as an
open position uh so you know our team is
should be four people it's three at the
moment um
it's a tiny team right and you know so
so managing people's time
it's kind of hard in the sense that it's
a small team but it's easy in the sense
that it's a small team and we're
typically going to work on one project
at a time right
um
so that's that's how we block it and we
just have we just take a very agile
approach so you know there's a typically
a planning sprint um that we take on
where we're
we're all as a team listening and
talking to
you know somebody that has a problem
that we need to solve
and then we're kind of
building a backlog building some sprints
uh working through it at each at each
iteration we're trying to show people
what have we created
um
uh is this helpful is this going to help
you towards your goal um so
you know
you know jira in the back end with you
know our our user stories and and kind
of uh issues and things like that is is
really i think you know the way i manage
people's time is you know assigning and
that sort of thing but because we work
so collaboratively um
i i don't have i don't really have the
the
it's not really a task on my plate to
care about what somebody's doing because
i kind of know what they're doing at any
given time
um
there are instances where we kind of
split up and do little things if there's
no if there's a lot of maintenance or
something that needs to be done but
again
i have a little view in jira i can i can
stare at and say
you know why is this sticking or
whatever so that that's kind of that's
kind of how we do it i'm
i'm kind of excited and scared for the
challenge of doing that when we have a
few more people in the team and we have
like multiple projects at the go on the
go at once um that's going to be a
little bit more challenging but
uh agile is a little bit easier because
the team holds each other accountable um
for
what they're supposed to do if that
makes if that answers your question
yeah thank you
thanks jay
thank you all for the great questions
too um i was curious jay as you
look ahead to
the next year or so what's something
that you're most excited about
oh yeah um so we recently uh made the
decision to move our data stack
over to
a google cloud storage and data bricks
so that's really really exciting for me
to have
you know kind of a fully managed spark
ml flow
on on google cloud storage from from uh
what i would call a pretty you know
traditional data warehouse type of model
uh though not so much but you know a
relational database has a lot of
uh limitations in terms of like
you know more modern applications that
are providing data to our our ecosystem
and so i'm really excited to kind of
move over to that that architecture
and kind of you know the work to convert
all our existing applications to to feed
into that might be might be a challenge
but
um it opens the door to so much right
like
like
most of the
our digital ecosystem now is is uh
all just done through json right and
putting that in a relational database is
a nightmare uh it's always a challenge
we have to make a lot of concessions and
you know in terms of the way we approach
modeling data um
we won't have to as much anymore and so
that's what i'm really excited about um
so that that's probably going to change
a lot almost everything about how we
solve problems and you know i love a
challenge and i love
learning a new tool so that's what i'm
most excited about for sure
that's great
i know we're
quickly coming up to the top of the hour
but just to go back a second i know you
mentioned you're hiring right now
yes what do you think is
i guess what is most important to you
and like
hiring for that role or what is
something you look for and the people
you hire
uh
i mean i i kind of just mentioned it it
was like
like if you're a little bit like me you
like to learn a new tool
you know obviously we work really
closely together so
being open-minded being
self-reflective
being able to give good feedback
you know like being able to contribute
an idea about how we can do work better
um is a really critical part and that's
you know as much as i'd i'd love you
know some absolute
like banging our expert with shiny
experience coming out to wazu
if if you can't work nice with another
team and your code isn't readable and
and that um
i i
i 100
wouldn't find useful right because we
have to work together i i you know i
might have to maintain your code
sometime and if you can't tell me what
you're doing it's not useful to me um so
we're really looking for
you know teamwork um collaboration
communication um
and at very minimum some are and
programming and get
experience yeah
that's great thank you i see libby said
well i wish i lived in canada
but we i will be sure to share it with
um
the linkedin network there too yeah that
would be great
what what's the best way for people to
stay in touch with you and
if they have follow-up questions is it
linkedin
uh yeah linkedin linkedin is good um
like maybe put a note when you uh if you
if you want to join my network put a
note that you saw me on on the on this
uh thing here just so i can sift you
from the sales people that hand me all
the time uh when you get that director
title uh i found like it's like
probably 95 of the requests that i get
are just somebody who will immediately
just try to sell me something um and so
uh i do get i do have to sift through
that a lot so yeah a quick note will
help me will help me uh
not ignore your request for a connection
uh sorry to sound uh
sorry to sound obtuse there but
no we will we'll be sure to add that in
there i won't put your linkedin in the
chat then just so it doesn't go to
youtube
thank you uh well thank you so i know we
just said the top of the hour but thank
you so much for joining us jay it's
great to hear your experience and and
learn from you really appreciate it
of course and thanks for everybody's
great questions and
conversation that was that was fantastic
thank you all have a great rest of the
day
you